THEY KNOW THE IRS WILL BE USED
TO AUDIT PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE
WITH THEIR LIBERAL INTERNATIONAL
ORDER.
AND NOW JOE BIDEN IS PROVING
THEM RIGHT.
HERE NOW IS NEWT GINGRICH,
AUTHOR OF HIS NEW BOOK ON
SOCIALISM.
I SAW THIS WEEKEND THAT THIS
WARMONGER SAID THAT YOU CANNOT
CALL AMERICA FIRST CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICANS ANYMORE, YOU HAVE TO
CALL THEM THE NEW FASCISTS.
THAT PASSES AS INTELLECTUAL
DISCOURSE FROM THIS SCARBOROUGH
BLUE CROWD.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT, THERE
WOULD BE 30 FBI AGENTS ENTERING
THE HOME WITH NO PARTICULAR
REASON, PICKING UP A COLLEGE
PROFESSOR AT THE AIRPORT AND
DELIBERATELY WALKING HIM IN
CHAINS TO THE AIRPORT TO
HUMILIATE HIM.
IT WOULD BE BASICALLY REPLACING
THE FBI WITH THE GERMAN SECRET
POLICE AS THE APPROPRIATE TITLE
WHEN I AM HAPPY TO HAVE A DEBATE
WITH PEOPLE LIKE MAX WHO ARE
APOLOGISTS FOR A FIELD
ANTI-AMERICAN ESTABLISHMENT
WHICH HAS YEAR AFTER YEAR FAILED
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, FAILED TO
DEFEND OUR INTEREST, FAILED TO
WIN WARS OR REFORM TO
BUREAUCRACIES, FAILED TO EDUCATE
OUR CHILDREN, PEOPLE LIKE THIS,
LIKE MAX, ARE THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF A DYING
SYSTEM, AS IT STARTS TO DIET
GROWS MORE DISPARATE.
AND YOU SAW LAST NIGHT IS THE
DESPERATION OF A REGIM